citizens of the reject Nation Greg here
today uh I'm going to be doing a first
time watching for a film that uh I was
supposed to do a couple months ago but
just due to scheduling because this is
one of those videos it's going to take
some time to prepare just due to the
length of the film and the subject
matter and whatnot so I was looking for
the right time to to cover this and
since we're going to be out of town for
uh the week of 13th through the 20th
figured yeah let's uh let's do this
let's we gotta I gotta get this up for
the end of the year I'm a little nervous
for for some reason just because of I've
heard how heavy this film is Schindler's
List is going to be watching Schindler's
List today if you guys can leave a like
I know you can that would be very much
appreciated also um full-length and
watch alongs where you sync up with your
own copy of Schindler's List I'm buying
this off Amazon available for super sexy
Rejects at our patreon page thank you so
much to all who have trainers support to
us on our patreon throughout this year
support has not been overlooked
sincerely thank you so much okay yeah
I'm a little nervous
I don't know why I'm nervous I'm a
little nervous Let's uh let's let's see
what just it just seems so you know such
a heavy drama it sounds like what I'm
walking into but it's spelled here it's
a masterpiece let's see what's in store
beautiful transition there
German forces defeated the Polish Army
in two weeks wow
it's already kind of got this like
fraught vibe
[Music]
I knew this would be in black and white
but I didn't expect to see Schindler
capture with this film Noir quality
bring them over a round of drinks
you can say they are from me I don't
know anything about this man other than
like the
semi-general story of what this movie is
about find out who he is
yes sir
stay here
Schindler seems like quite a Charming
Man and leave a woman alone at the table
in a place like this
[Music]
what was this man doing it's like
winning over everyone at this party
that's Oscar Schindler
[Music]
[Applause]
um
it's interesting something tops between
feeling like
cinematic Noir movie to almost a
historical documentary
I'm looking for it's extern
oh damn is that Ben Kingsley I didn't
know he was in this
simple engineering though wouldn't you
think change the machines around
whatever you do you can make other
things couldn't you
yeah once the war ends forget it but for
now it's great you can make a fortune
don't you think I think most people
right now have other priorities like
survival you must have contacts in the
Jewish business Community working here
what community Jews can no longer own
businesses that's why this one's
interesting question but they wouldn't
own it I don't it huh
they'd put up all the money I do all the
work what have you done Mama asking
would you do I'd make sure it's known
the companies in business I see that it
had a certain panache
Nation
there's so much performance in Liam
Neeson's eyes alone
in metal containers this is glass it's
not what I asked for my client sold it
to his client who sold it to the German
Army because of the freezing cold it
broke this is not my problem the German
Army wants to find out where it came
from now it's your problem
do you know where I can find a nice
shirt like that do you have any idea how
much a shirt like this costs nice things
cost money looks like you're in business
man
[Music]
foreign
wow
it could not be better
oh tell me how on Earth could it
possibly be worse
thousand you with vegetable repair with
200 kilos of an animal about a month to
begin in July and to continue for one
year not good enough look we are living
look we have been put money still money
mm-hmm
how do we know that you will do what you
say because I said I would
damn
what a way to take advantage of a very
unfortunate position it's outside the
ghetto so you can battle for extra goods
for eggs I don't know what you need with
the Polish work because you can't get it
here he's asking for 10 healthy women
for a day
bring your sister okay
you're a musician yeah yeah I find a
good hiding place if I were you I'm not
going to hide like some animal the place
is too high God this is so [ __ ] up I
teach history and literature it's when
it's not essential
it's metal polishing this is an insanely
well made film
it's not right very good he's 53 years
old it's too new thank you you're crazy
how many times have I told you your work
assistant did you keep in your pocket at
all times
oh he's I'm a metal polisher
[Music]
's the MVP of this movie huh filing
filling keeping track of my appointments
shorthand typing obviously a visual
therapy
all right please
this is masterfully edited
[Music]
I love her just lean back it's got
taller just getting closer and closer to
them enabling me to profit with absolute
confidence and pride a full line of
field and kitchenware unsurpossible in
all respects by my competitors
see attached to list and available
Colors oh Europe you're a clever
Schindler
my father was fond of saying you need
three things in life
a good doctor
a forgiving priest
and a clever accountant
it's a good saying
I'm trying to thank you
I'm saying I couldn't have done this
without you
the usual thing would be to acknowledge
my gratitude it would also by the way be
the courteous thing wow Ben Kingsley is
phenomenal just like the conflict of
working with this man
I'm so used to Liam Neeson performances
of the last 20 years it's fascinating to
see him play like a full-fledged
character be careful of the stepmis Mrs
Schindler married
[Music]
everybody remembers him
he did something
extraordinary he set out for a
particular Legacy
wound up with a different kind of Legacy
than planned
in every business I tried I can see now
it was me that failed something was
missing
if I'd known what it was there's nothing
I could have done about it because
because you can't create this thing what
was missing all the difference in the
world between success and failure
whoa
that is ugly business man promise me
Oscar
hello
[Music]
today
oh my God
they would have killed me
but I am essential to the war effort
thanks and to you that's great you are a
good man
hmm
don't ever do that to me again did you
happen to notice that that man had one
arm did he
someone's feeling guilty him and Ben
Kingsley play off each other so well I
have never seen any movie like this of
course seen movies that take place
during World War II but you know nothing
like this National priority that Jews be
made to shove us now juice shoveling
snow it's getting
richer significance our prick
come with me I work for Oscar Schindler
a sexual worker for Oscars
yes twice as useless
what the [ __ ]
I lost a worker
I expect to be compensated if I had a
grievance with the economic office it's
your right would it do any good that's
to believe the Jewish skate worker had a
place in right economics
was a reasonable idea he was a metal
press operator
quite skilled
so [ __ ] up my plant manager is
somewhere on this train if it leaves
with him on it it'll disrupt production
and the armaments board will want to
know why what is your name
my name is kunda
hops
I think I can guarantee you you'll both
be in southern Russia before the end of
the month good day
stand
stand
[Laughter]
there's some like real human touches of
humor here my apologies
what if I got here five minutes later
then where would I be
damn it's gonna destroy all this
foreign
[Music]
can you see it that's not a villa I need
to turn it into the camp Stables the
house
it's not over there
kindergarten 51. I just can't imagine
treating people like this just so
this what's her name and then here's
man
the entire Foundation has to be torn
down in a report I'm educated too like
Karl Marx himself
what the [ __ ]
here are you sick bastard
it will take more than that I'm sure
you're right
oh Christ
rebuild it like she said we have more to
see but we have only one more hour of
life
[Music]
why are they doing this
gotta preserve it hide it
[Applause]
oh wow
that's funny
good time
shoot him yeah
so diabolical
oh my God
[Music]
holy God
it's so horrifying
part of them death euthanasia
foreign
[Applause]
holy [ __ ]
women
so sudden
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
God damn it
why why
I can fit the girl but not you Mama I'm
Coming Out stay where you are I'd rather
you be here than who knows where
foreign
holy Christ
oh my God
I can
get under the stairs they'll be
downstairsing soon he'll be safe there
hide under the stairs
I've searched the building there's no
one here
wow
oh my God what
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
fascinating it's like a Red Shadow that
follows her too
[Music]
[Music]
let's go please
come on
different when you can see it huh
[Music]
lucky
oh my God
[Music]
ridiculously harrowing
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
just like transplants you into this time
man
monsters man
[Music]
this food does an incredible job at
throwing you into this
CD
hold harsh ruthlessness of the Nazis
and just that
desperate survival
for the Jews
like it doesn't even feel like I'm
moving a lot of times just
feels like capturing a moment in time
workers now
the worst is over
hell
they're not gone
they're here they're mine and they were
going to be making so much money none of
this is going to matter it's bad
business
thank you
just didn't make her a housemate huh you
could make things easier for me
be grateful
sucks getting it's better with this guy
sure I see my cut from the factory
owners in this camp
he wants his independence but
Independence costs money
God I [ __ ] hate these people
like you're like real life monsters am I
looking on you see how you're doing
you're a director don't let Things Fall
Apart I work too hard
I really hope he doesn't die
foreign
[Music]
come on man
oh that's very good
but you've been working since six this
morning yet
such a small pile of hinges
I gotta be [ __ ] me
crazy even here click it was the angle
of it maybe the pin this is
the machines were being recalibrated
this morning
I was put on to travel in court
come on just hear him out
strange huh
that's strange
nobody knows who stole the chicken
you committed this crime no sir but you
know who though
she shot the right guy I guess [ __ ]
hell
I just
it's treated like like they're nothing
it just feels like completely hopeless
my parents aren't washed off they're
killing older people now in Portia
please bring them here I don't do that
whether another worker has certain
skills that's what I ask and that's what
I care about my father is an important
not a metal worker interesting how they
frame him but is under enormous pressure
in normal circumstances he wouldn't be
like this he'd be all right a man who
loves good food good wine making money
killing he can't enjoy it yeah okay
somebody escaped from a work detail
Outside The Wire
God lined up everybody from the missing
Command products
shot the man to the left I'll be his key
the man to the right of him 25 25 people
sick
disgusting what do you want me to do
about it nothing nothing
well man
husband and wife
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
s from dinner
said to him
why are you beating me
he said the reason I beat you now
is because you ask why I beat you
you want to shoot because he enjoys you
too much
he doesn't want anyone else to know it's
a Jew he's enjoying
he shot the woman from the steps because
she meant nothing to him
I
go now man
everyone has to just accept the position
they're in
slave position they're in but also live
in a constant feel and fear
I could just die at any moment
it's disgusting you're nothing wrong
that's a little control
controller's power
that's power
like an enemy they fear that's because
we have the power to kill arbitrarily
a man commits a crime he should know
better we haven't killed and we feel
pretty good about it
will be killing myself and we feel even
better that's Justice
it's different than power
speak his language power
is when we have every justification to
kill
and we don't I don't think you can
convince this guy to do anything man
should I smoke you on the job tell her
not to do it again
kind of pardoned her
I've been unable to remove this change
from my bathtub
coming down soap not life
go ahead go and leave leave a pardon you
what
what
no this guy's gonna Resort back
please don't shoot him
pure evil man
a little boy was just like trying to
just walk away like it was fine
this is just evolving into
a sort of chaic Beast Specialties
again married
down here you know listening to everyone
upstairs having such a good time
what's he gonna do I would like so much
to reach out
to touch you in your loneliness
I mean
what would be wrong with that
so much
I mean maybe you're right about that too
you know maybe what's
what's wrong isn't
he's going through his own head he's not
even when they compare you to him
to uh verb into rodents into lies I just
no no you make a good point
this guy
is psychotic he is paranoid as [ __ ] too
he never talked me into it now
didn't you
[Applause]
what the [ __ ] man
well registered please thank you very
much for the lovely cake
oh wow
they must not respond well to this
man [ __ ] they're gonna be aware of the
Optics about things
they've got to separate the sick from
the healthy
to make room
so ridiculously dehumanizing
look alive Rebecca
[Music]
so messed up
pure savagery this is one of the most
horrified things I've ever seen I think
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what is kids doing they're just being
taken away from their families
[Music]
[Music]
like that feeling of her relief to think
it's gonna Live Another Day
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
so [ __ ] up
foreign
man
oh you gotta be kidding me
get out
I was supposed to get out when does this
movie become [ __ ] about shutters
lists
[Applause]
the suffering in this film
water the water's just right there
you say we got your fire hoses out here
and hose down the cars thank you
[Music]
[Music]
whatever he can help give them something
[Music]
clever
disguising it like
like it's a form punishment every time
the train stops you open the doors you
get the water yeah yeah this car this
car
what dude's gonna turn on you
foreign
music in this film
I kissed a Jewish girl
he likes good looking women he sees a
beautiful woman he doesn't think he's
defending him
this guy was wolf
very good looking he's defending her and
that's crazy
[Music]
it's Ash
[Music]
ten thousand Jews
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
coming back
that's the same little girl
[Music]
that's when the change that really
started to happen with him huh some days
this is all going to end you know
I was going to say we'll have a drink
then
I think I better have it now
should I stay alive my people I want my
people who are you Moses I know them I'm
familiar with them I don't have to train
them it's good for you I'll compensate
you that's right it's good for the army
look at this divide I'll go along with
it it's just irritating I can't work it
out look
can't fathom that he's sympathizing
what's a person worth no no no no no
what's one worth to you
sir the children
all the children all the children
how many
400 450. wow
[Music]
yes NECA
and one
just touching
600.
[Music]
for each of these names you're still
working for me I'd expect you to talk me
out of it it's caustic new fault
[Music]
all right it's whole time we didn't know
the list is an absolute good
the list
is life yep
it's margins lies the cup
Oscar there's a clerical error here at
the bottom of the last page no there's
one more name I want to put there I've
never find a maid as well trained as
heard of brilliant no way
she's just going to Auschwitz number two
anyway what difference does it not got
Auschwitz never do that to her no I want
her to come back to Vienna with me
couldn't work for me there you pig you
pig
you can't take it to Vienna with you
next most merciful thing shall take her
into the woods and shoot her Palace in
the back of the head
just not a [ __ ] like animal dude
I can't treat animal like that say your
names clearly they are the family
dresdenas
Henry mancy and Leo our son
hey oh boy
yaakov levertov
irus
[Music]
it's interesting mirror in the beginning
of this movie
Coral bits Dalek
actually something kind of hopeful where
would they go
[Music]
everything's been so horrible I'm just
want everything to go okay
it's Hometown huh
I know you've had a long journey
but it's only a short walk further to
the factory where hot soup
and bread is waiting for you
welcome to brindlets
please don't let anything go wrong
not the [ __ ]
what's happening mama where are we
they're in Auschwitz the train was never
rooted here a paperwork mistake
was it a mistake [ __ ] um
[Music]
what the what the hell is going on
is this really gonna happen
[Applause]
is this really gonna happen right now
okay
I think we're gonna cast
we work for Oscar Schindler who is Oscar
Schindler we had a factory in Krakow and
then we were
to make a
how old are you mother
damn it get them retrieve them
why do you think I can help you
could have you arrested
and protected by powerful friends all I
say is I am not comfortable with them on
the table
ah
well said
you shouldn't get stuck on names
her people not names
foreign
polish the insides of shell metal
casings how else am I to polish the
inside of a 45 millimeter shell Keys you
tell me you tell me
Jesus
damn sure's gonna get killed
he's gonna get [ __ ] killed just
making these judgment calls like
[ __ ] there will be no summary
executions here dogs will no longer be
allowed on the factory floor without my
authorization
wow
he's got to ride such a fine line with
that facade huh no doorman
or meter D will ever mistake you again
but you're just waiting for him yeah
I'll tell Michelle's thanks shells
rocket casings apparently all of them
have failed quality control to be
expected startup problems Stan if this
Factory ever produces a shell that can
actually be fired I'll be very unhappy
damn
God you know like I'm happy about the
moral choice but is leading to this
man's death what day is this Friday it
is Friday isn't it is it what's the
matter with you
you should be preparing for the Sabbath
I've got some wine
um
foreign
[Music]
do you have any money
hidden away someplace that I don't know
about
foreign
am I broke
General Joe
signed the act of unconditional
surrender
and the air forces in Europe
to the Allied expeditionary Force
the German war is therefore at an end
but let us not forget for a moment I
think it's time the guards came into the
factory
at midnight you'll be free and I'll be
hunted I shall remain with you until
five minutes after midnight
after which time and I hope you'll
forgive me
I have to flee
makes sense
received from his superiors to dispose
of the population of this camp or you
could leave
and return to your families as men
that really happened they really do that
the guards and [ __ ]
in memory of the countless victims among
your people
I ask us to observe three minutes of
silence
thank you Mr yeah
um I want that cloth distributed to the
workers
two and a half meters each
it'll be done everything you ask
we've written a letter
trying to explain things
in case you were captured every worker
has signed it
thank you
that's
what it says forever saves One Life
Saves the World entire
laughs
[Music]
[Music]
just
I love 100 people who are alive because
of you look at them
why did I keep the car 10 people right
there 10 more people
this is gold
two more people
one more person
ah
all right best
and I didn't
[Music]
guys so [ __ ] heartbreaking
[Music]
yeah
you have been liberated
by the Soviet Army
we could use some food
isn't that a town over there
you feel real to me
good
[Music]
wow really
[Music]
oh that's cool
I really thought they were gonna kill
him
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
that's cool that they're doing this
[Music]
no way
no way
oh
alrighty well look guys I'm gonna pull
up uh IMDb here just so I have character
names in front of me
uh yeah the uh what all I am recording
right I don't remember it recorded yeah
yeah I'm going all I can really do is
um
just sort of talk from where I'm feeling
right now yeah I'm not going to attempt
to try to sound intelligent so for those
who already think I'm not intelligent go
ahead have a go at it in the comments
um yeah obviously like
especially for a reaction it's a lot
quieter than I normally am
didn't even have jokes coming to mind I
feel like it would have been really
inappropriate if sarcastic Greg was
popping off after in this particular
movie and uh it is interesting uh
watching this because I've been wanting
to watch it for a few months remember
Community post when I was like do I
watch the history model or dances wolves
and people live for green Milestone over
that that was like months ago and
there's um
a lot of anti-Semitism going on in the
media this these days
so you watch something like this you
know like yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ] this is
This was
um
this this feels like a film that is
important this is something that was so
breathtaking like it's it's yeah it
shows the grotesqueness of it all it
shows how it's so grim and bleak
and sorrowful
all kinds of depressing ass words you
can throw at it but not in a way that
felt
exploitive
you know
it
it feels like a like a big scale
personal project for Steven Spielberg
I'd imagine so
I am curious to look up what awards this
one I I don't know if it wouldn't best
picture I I actually don't know what
awards this movie made uh garnered I was
Blown Away by it because you know it's
one thing to
hear about things that are great it's
not a documentary it's it is a film at
the end of the day
but that's what I mean by it's one of
those things that feels important
because it really
immerses you into it you know like I I
tried for my end because I was aware I
was in black and white I was aware three
hours so normally we got these lights
and they're like pointed right at me and
and I was trying to like push them away
so that way it could be a little bit
darker in here so I'm like brightening
up in the editing program I was trying
to give that experience but even with
with that I I found myself like just so
so lost in it it it's
like beautifully depressing I don't know
because it it feels so authentic and I
feel like you know knowing facts about
what went down
um in any type of horrible historical
event or even things that happened today
like hearing about it you know it's like
obviously if you hear about it versus
seeing you know footage that hits a lot
different and here they the the way
Spielberg uses like the the with the
pacing and like John Williams did the
score but yet there's so much of the
moments like especially in the most
harsh scenes uh like when when they are
just
when the Nazis are just taking all the
Jews and just slaughtering them or
shoving them around torturing them those
scenes like there was no music there and
that that lack of Music creates such an
atmosphere and a gripping way to suck
you in to have this feel as close to
feeling real as possible the basic bit I
knew was about Schindler making a list
to save Jews that's all I really do I
didn't really know much beyond that and
then so watching this so it was like two
hours and I was like what is the saving
of the chew's gonna happen when when's
that gonna go down because this is so
this is so hard to sit through I don't
know why that's like um bored or
something it's it is just it it felt
like it hit on such a a way that didn't
feel like I'm watching Cinema if even
though this is like pure Cinema it hit
on a way that I I felt like I was
watching a I was experiencing something
and I found myself going I'm craving a
bit of catharsis here to start getting
on like a heroic path and yet the the
cleverness of of I think the execution
of it is like you sometimes you cut away
from um Oscar Schindler for so long
and you're in the the depths of the
experience
of being a victim in this war
and so you're seeing like the depravity
of the Nazis the soullessness of them
and then you're experiencing
the
uh like Helen has that line about
accepting you know the position she's in
and it's like yeah it's like you you see
the way it's depicted here how there's a
you get if you're in the muck of it if
you're on the the end where the Jews
were at there is a point where I imagine
at least from the way the movie was
doing it where you do feel like a sense
of acceptance over it but that doesn't
mean it eliminates fear it doesn't mean
it eliminates the anxiety and the worry
you know the the fact that you die at
any given moment for no reason
thank you
and capturing that is the thing that
motive like because you get to feel that
and then when you do cut to
schindler-like scene the girl with the
the one where they put her in the red
dress
which I imagine
it's red so I'd imagine it would
symbolize the uh you know like the
Bloodshed during the Holocaust but also
as as a point because like he that the
needle starts to um to move for him in
that moment internally
on the situation at hand
with eyeing her but then when her body
is dead that's when it really propels
when he sees her dead body that's when
it really propels him like he's got to
really start making a difference here
like he's really affected by it and
that's kind of what I mean is like it in
a way with and I don't know if this is
intentional or not but you know like
Schindler is like yeah I can make a
profit off of War I get the factories
going but I'm not really privy to all
the Terrible Things the Nazis are
actually doing like the actual
slaughtering and the torture I'm not
really privy to what's going on there so
you know like if he keeps a barrier he
can just go about his work but then when
you know he's actually witnessing it and
then he's connected to I mean yeah
there's like the horrors before him when
he's when he's on that horse like men on
a hot horse on these are the [ __ ]
before him but then when he sees that
little girl you know like that hits on a
different level
and that's kind of what I was talking
about at the beginning of this
discussion is like it's it's one thing
when you hear about things but then when
you when you experience it when you
connect to it like it just hits you in a
much harsher level you know
and uh
yeah when it comes to real life
tragedies I'm gonna try to be as like
respectful as possible
because that just hits me harder than
anything else honestly like that that's
the stuff that hits me the worst
you know and knowing it's real like
knowing this really happened like I'd be
curious to go through like what you know
like fact versus fiction like what what
parts of these are changed uh for the
purposes of narrative storytelling I'd
be curious to go through that
I
I don't know the the parts where the the
Six Million Jews were killed that really
happened
and witnessing that here like that
oppression and the slaughter it just
angers me oh my God I just thinking like
it was so
it just breaks my heart it's uh it's
heartbreaking and then you know it's
it's when you connect it to today and
see what Jewish people have to go
through
it's it's funny it's ridiculous
it's [ __ ] awful
like it really is
anyway
sorry I've I've a few Jewish friends and
uh
yeah like just I don't want to bring too
much as much as I watched up a very
political film I don't worry too much
it's just insane how
so much of the trials and tribulations
and the suffering is very much ignored
like
it's saying to me it's just
it's insane anyway back to the movie
itself uh when the music was there it
was beautiful
uh Liam Neeson was excellent was he like
a well-known dude at this time because
it's just kind of funny when you think
about like Liam Neeson the meme today
it's like I'm Liam Neeson my daughter
she was taken like he's always like a
rough Gruff Action Hero now
and and then to see his character here
like I just believed Oscar Schindler
that's who I felt I was watching this
entire time and
um the person in his position being a
German you know being a Nazi and in his
position and and then like there's
already such an ingrained type of
you know it wasn't like it he was
instantly sympathetic for the Jews it
wasn't like he was instantly motivated
to be you know the Harriet Tubman of
sorts for the Jews like it wasn't that
wasn't the case for the guy
it it was such a real performance of the
evolution of of the choices he was
making and like like when he does talk
to that um if you have a position he
made but that old man with the one arm
like he the idea of coming to terms with
reality of like these are this is a real
person
um and then for him to be like being
praised or doing good when all children
want to do is just profit off of him and
then profit out like any of the workers
during the war in yada yada like to to
to to get in touch with his empathetic
side for this situation it was such a
real performance like it felt so so well
done and even though you know the change
has to happen even then you know the
change has to come the way it seeps up
on you like when he does decide to get
the parents names of when the when that
woman is you know begging to get the
parents over when she's like here the
Jewish people are safe
it it was such a natural transgression
to the point when he is crying at the
end of I could have saved more people I
could have saved more people
I could have done more like after all
that he gets to the point where he is
the one putting his life on the line
and he's even sort of exposing and
admitting to it in front of the the
guards you know he is putting his life
on the line this whole time for that
like it's like I don't even want to make
bullets that will actually
kill someone in a war I don't wanna I
don't want to succeed in doing that and
and that to know that like I wonder if
that is true those were those were
Schindler's last like the last thing he
laments with the with the people there
um because
like there's something so heartbreaking
and beautiful about that that's how I
feel about my YouTube views I'm always
like that could have gotten more
like to think about like he just did
something beautiful and amazing and he
and he went against his all the
conditioning you know
and he changed but all he thought about
was how there's more I could have done
that's powerful that's powerful he was
great his chemistry would Stern like
that's such a heart of the film Ben
Kingsley and him that's such a heart of
the movie of
you know because even Ben Kingsley
doesn't trust him or doesn't take much
of a liking to him knows he's just being
kind of used
but then you watch as Stern evolves
opening up to him being a little more
vulnerable to him showing that you know
you're the Schindler guy ain't such a
bad guy after all and seeing that there
is such a greatness in him like the
evolution of their friendship is
something so beautiful and Ben Kingsley
just knocked it out of the park like wow
phenomenal we're talking about acting
though like the scene stealer
as ugly as this is It's a mid it's
refined like
he is so
evil like he he is the definition of
evil
and he does the performance
so natural like it's it's insanely
believable how evil
and morbid and disgusting and repulsive
this individual is he plays him so human
which makes it that much more unsettling
because you never know what this guy's
gonna do you just never know if he's
just going to be like I'm annoyed at you
so I'm going to shoot you he was
um he was like a phenomenal performance
it's a phenomenal performance
like the three main there's a lot of
great stuff like every one they cut to
felt like I was watching a real person
like the three main guys in this movie
they absolutely Excel but to the entire
Supporting Cast every time you cut to
them I'm like did they hire an actor or
did they just hire a like a real just
some like a a Jew with some experience
or something like that I don't know you
know what I mean like where they didn't
want an actor for this day they just
wanted a real person like if my mind
would sometimes go there because
obviously like one of these when the
movie was shot there's no way they could
have got his own from actual World War
II to play these controls but I'm I'm
saying like it there was such an
authenticity at least the way it
registered that it felt authentic I
wasn't even thinking like who's this
actor because they they were just so
believable like everyone
was very believable it's insane the
cinematography is excellent you know
there's there's a lot of the the way the
the shots are from Silver doesn't
usually go like super handheld and I
felt like
I don't know if half this movie is but
but it felt like close to half of this
movie was handheld which I thought was a
really uh great choice that it didn't
abuse the handheld choice and it was
used at all the right times and it does
it would hop back and forth between
filming like you know uh like certain
shots that definitely felt like a
Spielberg movie but never in a way that
felt like Grand and full of wonder the
way you associate a spillwork movie to
be like I feel like it was really
pushing against being that to feeling
just incredibly real like honestly if I
didn't know that this was Stephen A lot
of the time there's a way with the way
Spielberg shoots movies now especially
in the last 10 years or so can't quite
put it into words but they all look like
a Spielberg movie to me like the way the
framing is done and the lighting it
there's they look like a Spielberg movie
and if I didn't know Spielberg directed
this I don't think I would have
I don't think I would have guessed he
directed it
yet there's still some of that Master
Craftsman [ __ ] at craftsmanship at hand
uh with the legendary still Steven
Spielberg this was a beautiful
experience and and not an easy one a
very uneasy one but you know like I it's
this one has come out 94 93
same year Jurassic Park came out did I
know that for Friar
man Spielberg is something else first
Jesus uh 93 yeah for a movie that came
out in 1993
doesn't feel dated one bit not a frame
of it feels dated this does not feel
like a movie made in the 90s it's
decades old and it feels like if like
this came out today I would
I don't even think of it in that frame
until now like this came out in the
early 90s I didn't even look at it like
that this doesn't feel like a movie that
was made it feels like a Timeless
classic I'm really affected right now
I'm really uh
uh that was
inspiring I'll never be as good of a man
as Oscar Schindler
that that was there's inspirational
qualities but it's it's one that you
know and with it talks about theme with
themes about
um I know I'm just kind of rambling here
with themes about like the power to
because they did some moments where they
would like mirroring
Ray finds and and Liam Neeson
where
I don't know it's kind of what was the
was the was the visual directing
language of it trying to say that
because like they go into business
together and blah blah because they talk
so much about the power of choice to
take a life and that whatever that line
is
um when he's talking where he finds when
he's drunk the whole thing leads to the
whole pardon bits that she'll learn some
other world could have gone down that
path but it's it is so much about like
the power of choice because Schindler
could have easily just turned a blind
eye shouldn't there could have easily
just not done anything he could have
just gone about his business and and
said yeah I'll just those are the Nazis
I can't disobey them like he he went he
went against the grain and he made a
choice a bold choice and so this is so
much about the Power of Choice
and I think that that beautifully
resonates throughout and you know they
talk a lot about us and there was a a
man full of gratitude and and I am very
grateful for this movie I'm very
grateful for this because this is
something that feels like I said it
feels
important educational and
um while tough experience
kind of a necessary one I think to to
sit through you know like shouldn't shy
away from it end the day
I didn't go through this
most of us did not go through this but
there were a lot of people who did so
coming to try to understand what it's
like the best way you learn from
anything is try to get a bit of that
Human Experience feel to it and I and I
feel like this really provides that that
Human Experience
so yeah
anyway
this was an interesting one thanks for
being here happy Hanukkah Merry
Christmas that this video should be
going out uh like two weeks before all
that right I think so I'm not sure
feel like it'd be really inappropriate
if I released
I will release this way before like at
least a week before then
[Music]